i want to talk today about corrective  beauty makeup  so i'm going to take our onyx  eyeliner from flower beauty  and as you can see one eye is just lower  than the other so this eye is more open  and this one is more closed so what i'm  going to do is i'm going to put this  on the upper water line and it's going  to open my eye to match this one check  it out  so not in even the lash line  only the upper water line  [Music]  pretty amazing right  let's see after i put some mascara on  for the final look i'm done now and i  feel like my eyes look much more even  than they did before  corrective eye makeup inner water line  on the eye that's more closed  [Music]  you